c'est un ami je vais vous dire qu'il
s'agit dans un instant et vous avez tous
comprendre chez vous vous allez pouvoir
gagner
grâce à lui la même somme qui va gagner
ce soir hashtag des pmp jeu car je vous
présenter et à chaque fois vous viendrez
ici derrière ce buzz heures pour
affronter ce garçon ce garçon allez je
vous dis tout de suite c'était au voilà
[Applaudissements]
histoire théo c'est notre stagiaire
alors à la belle vie là il est vraiment
mais comme sahin joue dix huit en tête
de ma mère et tout le toit bien en
inspecteur gadget
le gagnant colombo ont garé il est en
délire à chaque fois qu'est une enquête
il est là et le stagiaire jour à chaque
fois face à vous pour récupérer votre
cachée de ce soir
[Applaudissements]
c'est normal est ce que vous le
connaissez tous ici autour de la table
ont voulu parler bien sûr s'appelle mois
le vendredi c'est préparer ils ont mis
le vendredi c'est préparer n'en pense
que mathieu donc je croise très souvent
dans les locaux d'âge de zones sûres on
prend un café on discute
la curiosité est intelligent on sera
fille énormément on est très confuse
alors déjà un gros mytho autour de la
table d'un gros mytho la fabrique c'est
toi fabien arrête de me parler dans
l'oreillette merci bah oui j'ai un gros
mytho il est à ma droite c'est matthieu
delormeau
on n'a jamais parlé de deux de plus que
h2o matt pokora vient d'intégrer le jury
de the voice
de quel chanteur at il pris la place
sert gâte gabon 2 0 des gardes car on
regarde bien la caméra garou garou garou
vous confirmez vous chantez rendre à vos
questions dans les anges de nrj 12
comment s'appelle la nouvelle pub de
jordan au leur
[Musique]
e
manila minardi là c'est gagné
le verdict aujourd'hui
la cagnotte de théo et à 1000 euros ils
ont pour gagner la même somme que théo
on paye bien les stagiaires téléthon qui
faisait quoi vous avez perdu dieu il est
lourd voilà merci tout d'abord il a peur
à son petit frère sans déconner
anversois cuissard est qu'il est pas mal
quand il est pas mal mais bon hein on
dirait justin timberlake c'est vrai
c'est un bon présage pourquoi baril est
pas très gros lui et il est à quoi dans
la vie
il aime quoi ils aiment la musique il en
mai
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais il aime quoi alors il m il aime les
personnes qui n'en ont pas et le rescapé
coûte ce soir c'est ton style est dans
un jeu plus brune mais très jolie
apparemment séparés mais toi aimer 10
mois à thouars où il y en a une autre
date qui correspond à mon d'isabelle
combler les prises
oui mais moi aussi agréable ça peut être
votre fils dont elle était 11e au bout
c'est pas sympa en plus on s'est
rencontrés sinon et jean mi ah oui aussi
oui c'est votre fils aussi jean-michel
oui oui oui michel hanako réagit
philippe etchebest est un gros bosseur
justement combien p style 95 95 kg et
vous sont deux sans trois il dépasse
nationale chiffres 102 fais gaffe
n'était pas prêt si tu as besoin de
faire long feu dans la saucisse et un de
ses bons c'est mon dernier mot il fait
un mètre quatre-vingt pour 97 kg et
nohra
quel célèbre humoriste verra son
spectacle diffusé en direct sur ces 8 7
avril prochain rodrigues lemoine c'est
ça jean luc lemoine jeunes pilotes
[Applaudissements]
precepta rigole mais la somme et 1200 15
euros vous allez pouvoir gagner dans ce
[Rires]
que fait mimie mathy qu'on embrasse
alors 4,7 fois par épisode de joséphine
ange gardien
l'accusé doit à claque des doigts très
malade on appelle monsieur froussard
c'est ton prof est un homme froid s'abat
se croit sa prof d'histoire-géo ton prof
de quoi c'est le directeur de la licence
qui incarne alice concubin en tant que
tu l'as vu je m'entends de montcuq il va
être un temps plein autant de manques et
entendront que j entends tu les veux
bonsoir monsieur france ah oui tu es
homassel je suis en stage chez h2o je
suis en licence un peu comme en
troisième année vous allez bien oui je
voulais juste savoir par rapport à là je
vais bientôt vous rendre le rapport donc
tout se passe bien mais justesse que tu
l'as vu pardon pardon je vous rendrai
mon rapport de stage mais justesse que
tu l'as vu par contre si le tu l'as vu
ou pas je comprends pas bien mais ce
froid ça ouais mais comment le numéro
via le secrétariat de la licence infocom
demain tu change d'école mais est ce que
vous l'avez vu par contre c'est juste
cette question fait ce que vous l'avez
vu je crois qu'il faut mieux vous me
rappeliez fils comprend après le repas
d'époque
est ce que vous l'avez vu par hasard ce
froid ça monsieur froissart qu'on
embrasse schelin s'est perdu
[Applaudissements]
cherry hill a perdu non seulement
l'argent également sa mission
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à